my name is Tatiana svet Avadh nobody can
pronounce my last name that's courtesy
of my husband I went from Fisher to
spend about so it's yeah trust me it's
true love
I am indeed a scientist in Booz Allen
Hamilton yes
another Capitol Beltway banded and my
Joey today's science actually was a very
unusual and I've in a million years I
would've never expected to be a coder I
was a political scientist by training
working as a contractor working without
data and actually taking that data to
coders to make some sense out of it and
frankly I got tired of that because they
could never understand my data they
couldn't understand why cluster 1 1
cluster was important than the other
what the outliers were why what
something was important so I said to
myself well why am I talking to you guys
I'll just go out and code in comes mark
Weisman with his data community C with
his fantastic newsletter and a whole
bunch of local meetups
so I started go to PI ladies so Jackie
Castle Akita Connie ham I checked out
some groups that did our and I figured
why don't we just stuck with both as
long as I mastered the basics I should
be good well we all know what our is but
by now if we do if you don't sorry
I support several federal customers
let's leave it at that
and a lot of my customers work with
spatial data how did I started doing
spatial art so when I first started I
never work a spatial data in R or Python
in my life I always stuck with something
more traditional international
statistics the works until one time I
had an urgent project where we had to
use arc Pro because Millwood are crow
jays tools yeah we all love them and of
course in the worst time ever on a
strictest deadline it failed it failed
to launch just it will
it would crash and I did not have a bid
dataset it did not have a database as a
shaver I couldn't even open the data so
given two days I had to find another way
of how can I even look at the data
what's inside so Google is your help you
Google say ok spatial analysis and
income a lot of these awesome tutorials
from Raman lovelies from say Ross where
they talk everything about are like oh
my god I can actually look at my data so
that's how I came about studying the
starlings spatially with our and created
apparently quite a niche with my team
who's like oh my god you can do all this
stuff was something that we always
thought was traditional statistical
analysis let's look at correlation and
regression we can actually use geo
databases and shape files with that
awesome there are so many fantastic
packages in our I love them it's like
every time a new package comes out or
there is an update it's literally the
highlight of my day
well that and my my child's perform as a
school
true so I get I get to you the phone
calls guys not his father the Python I
the our person gets the daily phone
calls so what I love what our is first
of all I love the interface I'm an art
studio devotee I'm not saying this
because they're the sponsor I really do
our studio
I have apparently turned a lot of people
on my team to love our students as much
as I do and not do the will just do the
old school command line leave us alone
and of course Jupiter if you by the by
the way guys if you have never used
Jupiter Jupiter does have the arc
Colonel it's pretty interactive you can
upload your code the graphics are great
are the huge so for someone who's is as
nearsighted as me it's fantastic I love
them all environment I love how you can
do all kinds of spatial temporal
analysis these are just some of my
favorite packages I honestly can do the
whole presentation just talking about
which packages I liked in don't like but
these are the ones I use all the time
are GDL I would be lost without it
it's I can't do my work without algae
doubt if our GTL is not updated in my
system I am in trouble if you ever
working with geometries our gos is your
next big thing it's what I love about
both these packets if you run them
together it's a little bit one line of
code you have all your layers you have
everything if you're working with
statistics because hey Mars after all
this was created it was founded as a
statistical tool SP and in Gstaad and
spats that are fantastic current lab arm
I actually recently discovered a package
and it was awesome I had to do on
spatial regression using some spatial
temporal data in it did the work
famously it was so clean a lots of great
examples okay okay
late all programming languages there are
some good stuff about them there are
some not-so-good about them these are
what I call Tatiana's list of pros and
cons
you again you can use our Python or
whatever language you want for your
analysis here's what I found it to be
great with I love the the CLI you can
you can do the workflow you can see
actually what you're doing and how you
can code it up and how you can work with
algorithms on the graphics I've heard
some people before who especially the
critic sensing some warming they're not
they get the job done in the end let's
be honest we all post this on
powerpoints for our customers because
they especially the fail clients because
they are too afraid to look at our
Jupiter notebooks and they don't want to
mess them up the functions of spatial
packages um that is one of my big
favorite thing if I were to code the
stuff in geo pandas anybody knows Japan
does or pycelle these are the top just
special packages in Python they deal
with data manipulation they deal with
spatial processing they're great they
get the job done but if I want to do
daily manipulations in in Python of
spatial data it will make me do a lot of
coding I'm a lazy person on electro a
lot of code I'm good well I can just do
with just a few lines of code and get
the job done so you have a lot of
functions and it doesn't just feel
spatial
I do also a lot of time series I loved
in time series in our I actually
specifically requested my customers like
you know please do this an hour will you
mind yes multiple functions on variety
packages but is still not perfect
there's no such thing as a perfect
language and the console you have a lot
of libraries in I mean a lot and
sometimes you need to in order to get
the job done you will need to upload I
think one time I had up to 30 libraries
just in the good suggested job down to
do all over all of my analysis and it's
a lot and it's not always updated with
the most recent version of our so if you
try to manage you will get oh yeah that
function has depth
but this doesn't work so you got a fixed
days and not installed that do this oh I
don't have time if you guys don't know
about the data sets a lot of spacial
packages will have pre-loaded data sets
you can practice with what I found the
hard way was you don't have pre-loaded
maps of every single country all of the
European countries are there African
countries are there but if your customer
wants you to look at drought in the
Philippines you kind of screwed so what
I found is you have to find a map only
from someone else either a digital
budget librarian you're in the agency or
uploaded from just for somewhere else
which requires exa Kohli
I know some people can like kill me for
this and I like it how dare you
criticize 3d capabilities of are not
always there I love working with network
analysis and Network 3d and in neo4j
their quaint but if I were to do an
interactive presentation for my
customers I would go with linking by R
or Python to tableau or to plotly
tableau I know it's not the perfect way
because you have to get a get a license
but plotting is free especially if you
have a server and you can get the job
done
and if you're trying to zoom in for into
your Maps leaflet I found it to be
sometimes kind of spotty so particularly
again if it's my personal experience I
know people swear by leaflet great but
that's what I had here's just some of
the type of spatial analysis I have done
anything from hey we want to look at
where different cell towers are located
within the country are they in the
insurgent area versus in the government
controlled area if you are trying to
learn spatial art and if you're looking
for really great open source or deer to
play with there are I go I go to my four
top sources from whenever I'm learning
in your package I go to a chlid which is
the armed conflict language
I said on conflict location events
database it's fantastic and they have a
lot of notebooks you can play with then
there's also gdelt which is updated
every 24 hours and you can pull data by
Google query geo the GTL is your social
media it's your media it's in there
several tutorials by the way online you
can look at it especially if you're
trying to do network analysis or data
manipulation then deed it cuz the days
that can be a little bit complicated I
also like some also thank God some of
our federal agencies still keep the open
source data so National Parks great deer
to play with and I recently found out
that some of the GHSA this has about
appearing are Mia bowls so if you're
looking for infrastructure or you can
pull that you so here's just some of the
most basic visualizations that I have
done this is looking at um cell towers
locations within the the US and around
the world here's my favorite data said I
love working with a quad and I have also
turned some of my customers to work with
applet whenever they're learning and
looking at conflicts and refugee
movements this is actually looking at
fatalities are in four countries on the
Great Lakes region in Africa so from
2000 all the way to 2016 in what I love
about that data it's always updated so
if you have additional analysis from
other sources this is a great supplement
they love seeing that time sears oh my
god highlight of my day I cannot imagine
my data science life without doing the
time series in fact that's one of the
things they bring you for like can you
do a time series analysis but don't know
what it is but can you just do it so if
there's spatial temporal data
I just got yeah let's see how these guys
are moving the bad guys the good guys
where they are at and I can't be more
simple can we predict the future are has
by far some of the best time series
packages I'm not just talk about zoo XTS
it's it's fantastic and it works great
with spatial data and although you
present functions to clean the data here
is
this is um I try to replicate my work
for the customer or using vehicle data
where they move in with a particular
time period from 2012 all the way 2016 I
said clean and special costume before I
became an ADA science I my costume was
always involved with both people so if
you do and uh say if you do in terrorist
networks for example they have data
available online but this time I was
allowed to add the spatial aspect and it
was great
um where are these guys movement where
are these insurgent groups moving so
this is also aqua data and I'm looking
at three different and searching groups
in support who split up support for Boko
Haram I wanted to see what the classes
are are they need and it small are they
big which was like okay I pretty much do
it all the same there is so much you can
do when it comes to are and space shell
and and you can take it to the whole
next level and if someone tells you well
Python can do it better maybe he can
just for me if I'm doing a statistics of
spatial data I just asked it with our
and that's my preference they could
leave it and I'm done I'm giving you
guys back five minutes
here is my contact information
oh really yes see on it you can't type
yeah she's super study the scientists
but my email address is there I would
love for questions email me call me I'm
DC based if you're ever in Tyson's
Corner holler I would love to come on I
need an excuse to stick to someone as I
don't you cannot go train from the
Ironman I'm going out to meet with some
smart people thank you